hey guys so um oh boy welcome Zoo easy
Q's easy answers sky cool mines called
easy Q's what's yours gonna be called
I've asked the doctor asked doctor brief
that's a and then we call we've been
trying to force Bragan to have a youtube
channel basically jenna set the YouTube
channel up for her by basically I did
yes completely
why doesn't Jenna love us enough to play
Minecraft I don't want to get that old
you want to play - no I've no big white
ass something good they know you don't
game classic
Cody Joe wants to know if we've ever
noticed that Bri looks kind of like a
morph between you me and Jenna she'll
beauty a little bit see that our girl a
day arcade company t3t Sophie wants to
know do you guys even have Bo friends Bo
you friends what wasn't with a Bowie
friend don't you have a friend named
Belle yeah but it'd still be on you Bo
Bo you Billy MOA with the ocean around
comb you shouldn't think I'm scared I
can't swim I don't have any friends that
my hair Charlie things no neither good
question though that was a great
question I've never heard of guys what
is our favorite childhood memory
together when you put me in the box and
made me D baby Jesus we're tied my hands
behind my back until you do a cartwheel
you also until we the sand on the edge
of the couch and do a backbend and I'll
so magically do a back tuck
I have my head
when yourself business today
I don't either do you ever feel like the
other Osborne sister
oh this was hashtag minute Sabri Killian
that Jack there is enough she didn't
want things she did a good job and she
did good job without me and lately on my
channel are the three DS Eric sisters
ever coming to London together hopefully
in Australia yeah we won't plan in
Australia trip but we need to find a
sponsor because yeah is a big bet right
that's a lot of a trade we should be
thinking ugh this bread in life
I'm wetting mugs are fabulous I want to
make it those I'm hungry love that no
sparkly purple your ass should be sure
everybody tweet them Australia you guys
want to come to Australia tweet uggs and
tell them to send our eye where are my
arms I'll wear them on my head I'll wear
them on my body I'm just one who's the
best driver made me okay wait let's go
Google line up
you have hits you've hit a car the only
thing I've done was hit on Iran's door
went through the garage no another on to
our next question
I'm the best driver oil guys guys how
would you describe your encounter with
Bigfoot
Mena's found I will describe its hours
and in that video Riley if you could
travel back in time what would you
change about your life I've got a
different orthodontist ah Michael you
know what I also do I go to a different
high school here at Rice 3130 brain was
long with your high school experience
you know what I would leave I would also
help tell us about it tell us if
brilliant tell us I might spit on my
Walker they wrote me a note yes tell us
about it it was my freshman year and
lose your senior the same high school as
you your senior knows prep see see but I
was it I was tough so I didn't care you
are a bad person if you're being bullied
end up in jail actually they do in the
long run bullies end up getting shot
because people come in and shoot them
I'm just enjoying this conversation did
you bully your going to jail and the
story next I just want everyone to sigh
all well what about me out what did I
not get bullet yeah I remember I wasn't
I don't think I was even like cool bull
much of a lizard even billion party yeah
would you guys have any fond memories of
we're no I was so you see what you can
nap in client and before I can blink
it's a better guitar solo these are and
used to play it so loud McCain you guys
you know what I don't think I hit record
okay I did what I used to meet each
other in the breeze Jenna didn't have a
roof cadet I didn't cherry I defile and
watch you having a sticker on her window
to did something there's baby in there I
had one ago you and what do you have oh
yeah I still have to say it's a hot spot
oh it's like my spot I thought hot spot
think that took like twenty three spot
don't was all spot when there were just
tricking humans spot yes for you guys
and put my fire a piece of I'm just
nothing with women right now if there is
a fire the first thing that you want to
do make sure you guys close the doors
behind you because the ventilation is if
I have so much faster
Janna is a fire marshal um do you have
another country that you would like to
visit which country where where where
Andy says I went to escape Pennsylvania
lol do you regret leaving or did you see
it as an escape - yes I thought doesn't
escape ain't gonna come back
backstreet's back alright
my editor know I was singing a nice ok
what you're saying um if you want to
escape you can escape no we can stay -
okay one more question how long did it
take you to convince is free to finally
make our YouTube channel we already
answered that I didn't make it she still
isn't convinced stupid three of you guys
get along as kids no no no well you were
able
barnable you just told these people not
to pick on people or would like it yes
so I'll just pick pick pick skis fish
hashtag don't should every t-shirt pick
pick Cibrian asked me nicely the socks
so I'm gonna stop all these people get
me on I guess I gotta stop very much in
your video do they Mosley I know just
close your eyes and pick one since you
can't read it have you ever heard of
cher Lloyd or Ed Sheeran no not all
question let me put one no stop right
there that one what are the DNA
isolation methods used to extract
proteins from cells
that's our DNA isolation methods used to
extract written week 11 versus there's a
couple holes in them of course I think I
paid attention I forget
Tom Daley or Justin Bieber don't know
who Tom is so they'll a no idea real
cutie
oh let's suck it Tom Daly oh sure he's a
little swim right yeah yeah because when
I search Tom Daly like the second thing
that shows up it's Tom Daly and then Tom
Daly bulge was the second closer that's
great hey Wow Justin Bieber by there
don't get leave oh no no oh okay Tom
these Google images are foul for 1994 94
oh my gosh we can't even look at those
legally turn this off he's 18 alright so
thanks for joining us guys wait I'm
looking at the DNA so now your daily
pick oh my gosh I look out my window as
good as the beaver balls all right guys
thanks for watching I got a fever boat
oh gosh hashtag bulge I'll see you later
I'm gonna go take it spider webs hotter
winds leave a message and I'll call you
back later
so what DNA isolation is electrophoresis
what are the ones but they measure the
welcome spider with others are the hard
to reach
Aryan that's dick pics huge
get jump pic pics get pic pics get huge
I was the same side we're done
necesito